allez vas-y aller à l'état taille et
écoute on va pas rester comme ça toute
la journée
bon écoute tu dis quelque chose allait
alors comment bonsoir c'est tout dit
c'est pas grand chose a dit à tailler ta
taille et écoute tu peux pas raconter
une histoire un poème par exemple tu
peux dire un poème un oui allez alors je
te sais que tu te dis bien mignon et
dieu joli nom donne vous les voulez voir
le jour à 6 chez mouge découvre
puisque tanner déniché cette affaire là
c'est l'instituteur qui nous attriste
dis-moi tatayet tu n'as rien d'autre
écoute je vais être obligé de faire un
sketch tout seul alors d'un accord
journal des sourds et des malentendants
états unis la maison blanche menace de
couper les crédits militaires au
président ronald reagan a déclaré qu'ils
ne tiendraient pas compte de ces
avertissements vatican vu son état de
santé
le pape pas puis ne pourra se rendre
l'été prochain en amérique du sud
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'attachés c'est pour les
souverains sport en hockey et les études
les états unis
ont battu l'italie domination
territoriale et en tennis de table
le chili a écrasé la belgique cherche
est quand même quelque chose
voilà dans quelques instants sur la
première chaîne
un film ma femme s'appelle reviens sur
la deuxième chaîne une émission de
variétés champs elysées avec avec
thierry le luron
jacques chazot roland magdane et serge
gainsbourg 6
[Applaudissements]
nous annonce
on nous annonce pour demain une grève
très probable des chemins de fer
attention donc les quelques rares trains
circulant risque d'être bourrée
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]